19살의 콜롬비아대를 수석 졸업하고 오픈 AI에서 일하다가 나온 사람이 AI에 관련된 펀드를 한다라는 어떤 내러티브 자체가 스토리 자체가 시장에서 너무 관심을 끌고 있는 거죠.
이번 분기 포트폴리오를 보면 이분의 탑픽이 결국에
뭘가에서 가장 주목받고 있는 AI 천재 투자자가 어떻게 투자를 하고 있는지 좀 알아볼 거고요.
오늘의 주인공은 레오폴드 아셴브래너라는 독일계 분이신데
정말 이력이 특이합니다.
나이가 01년생, 02년생 정도니까 만 23에서 24살 정도인 진짜 어린 친구인데
이 친구가 왜 이렇게 월가에서 주목을 받느냐 이력이 정말 특이해요.
독일에서 태어나서 자랐는데 독일 학교 문화에 답답함을 느꼈다고 합니다.
근데 이 친구가 15살에 미국의 명문대학교 중에 하나죠.
콜롬비아대학교에 15살에 입학을 해요.
그리고 19살에 졸업합니다.
졸업을 하는데 19살에 졸업을 할 때도
이 발레딕토리안이라고 해서 최상위권으로 졸업을 해서
졸업 연설 같은 거를 한 그런 사람을 이 발레딕토리안이라고 표현을 하거든요.
남들 대학교 들어가는 나이에 콜롬비아 대학교의 최우등 졸업생이었다라는 거
뭐 그런 것도 재밌고 경제학 수학 통계를 또 전공을 했고
복수 전공을 했고요.
졸업 이후에는 옥스포드에 잠깐 경제학을 연구하기도 했고
FTX에서도 잠깐 펀드 운용을 하기도 했고요.
FTX가 비상장 펀드 투자를 정말 잘했던데 이 친구가 한 건가?
뭐 이런 생각도 들고
어쨌든 UNFTX는 나왔고요.
그래서 22년, 23년에 오픈 AI 슈퍼얼라이먼트 팀에 있었고
그 이후에 이제 또 이 친구가 유명해졌던 게
오픈 AI를 떠나자마자
situational awareness라는 글을 썼는데
이게 이제 무슨 글이냐면
이 situational awareness라는 홈페이지도 있고
이제 자신의 글을 썼는데
뭐 대략 어떤 느낌이냐면
2020년에 오픈 AI 슈퍼얼라인먼트 팀에 있었고
2027년에는 AGI가 가능할 거고
왜 그러냐면
AI가 AI 연구를 자동화하기 시작하면
스스로 개선이 될 수 있으면
그 다음부터는 AI의 능력이 이제 엄청나게 빨리 향상이 될 거다라는 거죠.
지금은 너무 당연한 얘기일 수도 있는데
이미 2024년 6월에 데이터, 전력, 반도체, 보안
이런 것들이 AI 시대의 핵심 병목이 될 수 있다라고 주장을 했습니다.
그리고 또 미국과 중국의 AI 경쟁이
이제는 국가 안보 이슈로
국가 안보 이슈가 될 거다라고 했는데
사실 지금 읽어보면
뭐 너무 당연하다 싶은 이야기이긴 한데요.
2024년에 이 주장을 했다라는 거는
상당히 의미가 있다라고 볼 수가 있겠죠.
자 그런데 또 흥미로운 게 뭐냐면
이런 글을 쓰고 나서는
아예 투자사를 설립을 했어요.
그러니까 해치펀드 운용을 하게 된 거죠.
그래서 해치펀드 운용을 하면서는
이 AI와 연관된 회사들을 투자를 했고
이 친구의 이 펀드 자산 규모가
맨 처음에는 한 3년 정도가 됐는데
3천억 원으로 시작을 했는데
가장 최근에는 13F 기준으로는
한 18조 정도?
그러니까 뭐 60배가 늘어났다
이렇게 볼 수도 있긴 한데
이 13F 공시라는 것 자체가
옵션을 보유하는 것에 대해서는
이 자산 규모가 뻥튀기 되는 경향은 있어서
그래도 수조원 정도는 운영하는 걸로 추정이 되고요.
그래서 만만한 분은 아니신 것 같고
또 여러 가지 기사를 찾아보니까
수익률이 상당히 나쁘지 않았던 것 같습니다.
그래서 첫 6개월도 47%의 수익률이었고
2026년 연초 대비 수익률이 100% 이상이다
라는 그런 글도 있었어요.
이게 막 모두에게 공개된 데이터가 아니라서
정확한 수익률을 추정하기는 어렵지만
알려진 몇 가지 언론에 알려진 바에 따르면
수익률이 상당히 좋은 걸로 보이는 데다가
19살의 콜롬비아대를 수석 졸업하고
오픈 AI에서 일하다가 나온 사람이
AI 관련된 펀드를 한다라는 어떤
내러티브 자체가 스토리 자체가
시장에서 너무 관심을 끌고 있는 거죠.
그래서 이분의 13F
이분이 3월 31일 기준으로
어떤 종목을 보유하는지를
오늘 좀 말씀을 드리려고 합니다.
참고로 혹시 모르실까 봐 말씀을 드리면
이제 13F라는 거는 미국에서
운용자산이 어느 정도 되는 사람들이
주로 기관들이겠죠.
그래서 분기별로 자신의 보유주식
여기서 보유주식이라는 거는 현물도 있는데
푸드옵션이나 콜옵션의 노셔널 어마운트를
공개하는 그런 거를 13F라고 합니다.
근데 이거를 실시간으로 공개해주면
우리 같은 개인들 입장에서
개꿀이겠죠.
그러니까 실시간으로는 공개를 하지 않고요.
보통은 이 분기가 끝나고 나서
3월 31일이면 5월 15일 이후에 공개를 하는
45일 이후에 공개를 하는 형태로
진행이 되고 있습니다.
그러니까 이분의 포트폴리오를 말씀을 드릴 건데
그게 이제 3월 31일 기준이다라는 거
그러니까 45일 사이에 뭔 짓을 했을지는
그 누구도 모른다라는 거죠.
얘기를 드릴 건데
원래 13F 하면 워렌버핏이나
조크밀러나 제가 그런 분들 컨텐츠도 많이 했는데
그것보다 가장 최근에는 이분이 좀 재밌어서
유튜브는 뭐 제 마음대로 하는 거 아니겠습니까?
이분이 실제로 월스트리트에서도 상당히 주목받고 있고
이분의 포트폴리오도 흥미로워서
한번 이렇게 다뤄보게 됐습니다.
참고로 지난 분기 기준에서 포트폴리오를 보면
편의상 현물을 갖고 있는 것과
콜옵션을 갖고 있는 거는 그냥 합쳐버렸어요.
그 당시에 1위는 코어위브였고
2위가 블룸에너지
3위가 인텔
4위가 루멘텀
각자 좀 엣지가 있는 회사들이죠.
그러니까 코어위브는
네오클라우드의 대명사다라고 볼 수가 있겠고
블룸에너지는 에너지쇼티지
SOFC 연료전지를 만든 회사인데
에너지쇼티지의 대명사인 회사죠.
인텔은 여러분들이 아시는 CPU 만드는 회사고
루멘텀은 광통신 관련된 회사 중에
대장주라고 보시면 됩니다.
그리고 코어사이언티픽이랑 아이랜 같은 경우는
다 원래 암호화폐 하다가
AI 데이터 센터 비즈니스로
피보팅을 하는 그런 회사들이라고
이렇게 볼 수가 있겠습니다.
이때 포트폴리오만 봐도
수익이 나쁘지 않았을 것 같아요.
이게 참고로 이번 분기가 아니라
25년 12월 31일 기준이고
26년 1, 2, 3월 동안에
이 주식들의 성과가 꽤 괜찮았습니다.
그래서 이때도 아마
이분의 포트폴리오를 참고를 많이 하신 분들은
수익률이 나쁘지 않았을 것 같은데요.
자, 이번 분기로 돌아가서
이번 분기 포트폴리오를 보면
이분의 탑픽이 결국에 샌디스크입니다.
그래서 샌디스크는 이따가 뒤에서 얘기를 해보고
샌디스크 블룸에너지 여전히 보유하고 있고요.
코어위브, 코어위브
아까도 말씀드렸던 네오클라우드 업체들
아이렐리나 코어사이언티픽도 비슷하고요.
이런 포트를 가지고 있다라는 게 조금 흥미로운데
개인적으로 더 흥미로웠던 거는
푸드옵션을 또 가지고 있다는 거예요.
그러니까 푸드옵션이라는 거는
주식이 하락해야지 돈을 버는 베팅이거든요.
근데 이분이 이번에는
푸드옵션을 상당히 많이 샀다라는 게
좀 인상적이었습니다.
특히 이제 SMH ETF를 또 푸드를 샀고
15%나 노셔널 어마운트 기준입니다.
이 사람이 투자한 금액보다는
훨씬 더 많은
주식을 움직일 수 있어요.
이 SMH라는 ETF의 푸드옵션을 샀고
엔비디아, 오라클, 브로드컴, AMD, ASML, 인텔 등등
그러니까 얼핏 봐도
반도체 대기업들이에요.
미국에 상장한 반도체 대기업들이고
SMH도 사실은
SMH라는 ETF 자체가
미국 반도체
여기 최상위권 종목들을 보시면
엔비디아, TSMC, 브로드컴, 인텔, AMD, 마이크론
뭐 이렇게 있으니까
이거 자체가 뭔가
미국 반도체 전체를
숏하는 느낌?
푸드옵션으로 약간 숏하는 느낌?
이렇게 있다라는 게
매우 매우 흥미로운 부분이 있습니다.
그리고 또 하나 흥미로운 거는
마이크론이랑 TSMC는
콜옵션도 샀고
푸드옵션도 샀다.
이런 것들 흥미로운데
너무 옵션 얘기하면
어쨌든 머리가 아프니까
마이크론이랑 TSMC는
상승과 하락에 모두 배팅했다
정도로 설명하고 넘어가고요.
근데 이제 개인적으로 흥미로웠던 거는
미국 반도체 전체는 안 좋게 보는데
그중에서
내가 선택한 몇 개는 좋을 거다라는
일종의 좀 롱쇼스러운 접근을 하고 있어요.
내가 좋게 보는 거 롱
내가 싫게 보는 거 숏인데
같은 섹터에 있다라는
그런 접근은 흥미로워 보이긴 합니다.
근데 이때 포르무즈 이슈의
좀 한가운데여서 그런가
뭐 이런 생각도 좀 들고
그리고 또 한 가지 흥미로운 거는
이제 루멘텀 같은 회사는
전략 매도를 했다라는 거
이런 게 좀 흥미롭습니다.
루멘텀은 지난 분기까지는
좋게 가져갔다가
이제 이번 주에
지난 분기부터는
루멘텀, 광통신
좀 이제 재미없겠네라고 생각을 하는 거 같아요.
결국에 이제 친구의 머릿속에 생각을 보면
미국 반도체가 전체적으로는
매우 크게 흔들릴 수도 있는데
내가 고른 종목들은 상대적으로 좋을 거 같아
라고 생각하는 거 같습니다.
그래서 샌디스크, 블룸에너지, 코어이브, 아이렌인데
오늘은 샌디스크 얘기를 좀 해볼게요.
왜냐하면 뭐 별건 아니고
샌디스크 투자하는 사람들이 은근히
제 주변에 너무 많아.
그리고 이 친구의 탑픽이기도 하니까
이분의 탑픽이기도 하니까
샌디스크를
우리가 한번 좀 얘기해 보는 게
의미가 있을 것 같습니다.
샌디스크 올해만 해도 무려
379%가 올랐고요.
연초 대비는 무려
야 이거 실화냐?
3200%가 올랐습니다.
자 샌디스크
자 뭐하는 회사인가요?
여기 보이시나요?
제가 샌디스크 USB를 쓰고 있습니다.
샌디스크 유저야.
와 내가 쓰는 거였네.
그래서 이런 USB 메모리나
아니면 디지털 카메라에 들어가는
SD 카드 같은 거
이런 거를 만드는 회사가
샌디스크
샌디스크고요.
그리고 뭐 여러분들도 잘 아시는
샌디스크의 지금의 밥줄이죠.
그러니까 ESSD라고 해서
데이터 센터에 들어가는
카드 디스크보다는 조금 더 빠른
그런 걸 이제 SSD라고 하는데
저장장치를 만드는
그런 회사가 바로
샌디스크입니다.
뭐 짱 센 디스크죠.
물론 오늘은 좀 박살나고 있으니까
김샌디스크일 수도 있는데
어쨌든 지난 6개월간
지난 1년간 주가가 짱 셌기 때문에
저는 짱 센 디스크라고 부르겠습니다.
샌디스크가 급등한 이유는
랜드 사업 전체가
좋았다기보다는
랜드를 갖고
ESSD라고 하는
방금 보여드린 이
데이터 센터에 들어가는
연구 저장장치죠.
일종의 거의 뭐 연구에 가까운
반연구 저장장치를
만드는 회사이고
이 비즈니스
이 SSD가 워낙 잘 됐는데요.
그 ESSD 시장에서는 사실은
가장 좀 애매해
사실 이게 돈이 제일 많이 되는데
5개 업체들
이 랜드를 많이 만드는
이 빅5 업체들
업체들 중에서는
가장 좀 꼴등이다
이렇게 꼴등이라고 하니까
좀 그런가 어쨌든
시장 점유율은 낮은데
왜 이렇게 샌디스크 주가가 좋았냐
라고 물어보신다면
한 여러 가지 이유가 있겠지만
그 중에 하나는
샌디스크가
회사가 너무 안 좋았어
너무 회사 상태가 안 좋아서
주가의 시작 지점이 너무 낮았고
상대적으로 삼성전자 SK나 마이크론
이런 회사들은 덩치가 너무 큽니다
그러니까 막 3,000% 오를 정도의
그런 회사는 없었고
3,000% 오를 정도의 회사는 아닌 거지
애초에 시가총액이 그래도 다
100조는 넘는 그런 덩치의 회사들이었기 때문에
상승의 어떤 폭이 좀 한계가 있었다면
샌디스크는 정말 작은 회사였어요
그래서 상승률 자체는
작은 게 훨씬 더 많이 커질 수 있으니까
상승률이 좀 더 좋아 보이는 게 있고
또 샌디스크가 주가가
지난 1년간 괜찮았던 이유 중의 하나는
샌디스크가 또 투자자 입장에서
좀 매력적인 부분 중에 하나는
퓨어 플레이어다 라는 겁니다
삼성전자 하이닉스 마이크론 같은 경우는
메모리도 하고
낸드도 하고
이 두 가지를 동시에 하는
참고로 낸드로 SSD를 만드는 거예요
어쨌든 나는 낸드 사업에만
산업에만 투자를 하고 싶어 라고 했을 때
대안은 샌디스크 아니면 키옥시아 밖에 없긴 합니다
근데 키옥시아는
일본 주식시장에 상장되어 있는 데다가
일본 주식시장은 100조씩 매매를 해야 돼서
상당히 좀 매매하기가 불편한 부분이 있거든요
그러다 보니까 미국 개미들 입장에서는
개인들 입장에서도 그렇고
샌디스크가 더 뭐랄까
선택지가 되게 무난한 선택지야
미국 기업이지
또 소액으로도 투자 가능하지
덩치가 작은 기업이다 보니까
상승폭도 훨씬 더 크고요
샌디스크가 상대적으로 주목을 좀 많이 받았습니다
뭐 여러분들 다들 아시겠지만
이제 잠깐 있다가 사라지는 건 메모리
영원히 남아야 되는 거는 SSD나 HDD
하드디스크에 저장을 하죠
그래서 이 SSD가 데이터 센터
그리고 AI와 함께 각광을 받으면서
이게 엄청 잘 되고 있는 거고요
그래서 아시겠지만
이런 HBM이나 DRAM에 있는 것들은
컴퓨터 꺼지면 사라지는 데이터입니다
대신에 이제
용량도 작고 속도가 빠르죠
그런 특징이 있고
이 SSD나 하드로 가면 갈수록
점점 용량당 가격은 저렴한데
용량도 훨씬 더 크고
다만 읽기 처리 속도
이런 건 좀 느리죠
하드디스크가 제일 느리고
SSD가 이제 메모리와 하드디스크 사이의
그런 속도다
이렇게 보시면 될 것 같아요
그러면 왜 이렇게
랜드 시장이 그러면 뜨겁게 불타올랐느냐
최근에 이렇게 불타올랐느냐라고 물어보신다면
랜드 시장을 뒤바꾼 건
제가 보기에
추롱과 서비스로
서비스 백엔드인 것 같아요
자 이게 좀 말이 어려운데
쉽게 말하면 학습은 이제 더 이상
AI에서 리소스를 많이 먹는 부분은 아니게 됐어요
학습이 덜 중요해서가 아니라
학습을 한번 하고 나면
이제 쓸만한 AI가 만들어지는데
이 AI를 사용하고자 하는 수요가
지금 너무 폭발하는 상황이다 보니까
AI를 사용하려고 하다 보면
당연히 앱의 백엔드를 통해서
인퍼런스 추론이라는 걸 해야 되거든요
그러다 보니까
이게 이제 지금 시장에서
가장 뜨거운
감자다 뜨거운 감자인 상황
그런데 이 뜨거운 감자 앱의 백엔드
참고로 이제 앱의 백엔드라고 하는 건
아주 단순하게 생각하시면
여러분들이 클로드나 채찍피티를 열었을 때
여러분들의 눈에 보이는 그 모든 것들이
사실은 거의 백엔드라고 보시면 돼요
뭐 화면이 보이고 로그인을 하고
거기에 보면 지금까지 입력했던 다양한 글들
아니면 이제 AI가 보내준 답변
또 이런 것들이 다 존재하잖아요
그게 사실은 앱의 백엔드라고 보시면 됩니다
사실 뭐 프론트엔드다거나
프론트엔드도 섞여 있긴 한데
어쨌든 앱의 백엔드를
여러분들이 이제 보시는 거고
실제로 여러분들이 거기서
프롬트를 입력하면
AI가 뭔가 해결해 줘야 되는 부분들에 대해서는
이제 인퍼런스 클러스터로 가서
이제 수행을 하게 되는데
그냥 여러분들이 얼핏 생각해도
여기에 데이터가 얼마나 많이 필요하겠어요
그러니까 옛날에는 사람들이
뭐 PDF를 넣겠어
옛날에는 정말 질문만 하고
답변만 받았는데
요즘에는 거기다가
수많은 데이터를 다 올리죠
나와 관련된 데이터 그냥
다 올려서 해줘라고 하기도 하고
그냥 이제 질의응답받는 채팅형 화면에서
또 많은 파일들을 올리는데
결국 그런 것들을 다 SSD에 저장을 해야 되거든요
하드디스크 너무 느리니까
물론 하드디스크의 일부도 저장하겠죠
근데 어쨌든
수많은 내가 올리는 데이터들을 저장을 해야 되고
심지어 이제 에이전틱 AI의 시대가 왔으니까
에이전틱 AI도 결국에
정말 극단적으로 말하면
AI가 내 컴퓨터를
내 허락을 받아서
내 마음대로 쓰는 거거든요
근데 내 컴퓨터를 쓰면서
얼마나 많은 데이터들을 만지겠어요
인공지능이 이제
업무를 수행하는
테스크를 수행하는 인공지능으로서
지금 탈바꿈하고 있는 중인데
인공지능이 인간이 시키는
더 많은 일들을 하기 위해서는
인공지능에게 더 많은 데이터가 필요합니다
그러다 보니까 그 많은 데이터를
물론 이제 메모리도 필요한 거고
그래서 메모리에 저장해야 되는 것들도
많아지다 보니까 메모리도 많이 필요한데
또 더 많은 데이터를 SSD에 저장하는 부분들도 있다
그러면서 이제
이쪽 시장이 엄청나게 불타오르고 있다는 거고요
그래서 보시면은
과거에는 학습 추론 때문에
스토리지에
스토리지가 필요했다면
이제는 추론과 백엔드 때문에
이런 스토리지
그러니까 메모리나 SSD가 필요해지는
그런 상황이 생기고 있습니다
특히나 이 새로운 랜드 수요가
전 되게 중요하다고 생각을 하는데요
여기서 이제 새로운 랜드 수요는
KB Cache 풀과
유저 에이전트 데이터인데
유저 에이전트 데이터는
여러분들이 어느 정도
이해가 가실 거라고 생각을 해요
왜냐면 내가 지금까지 채찍 PT랑 대화한 거
클로드랑 대화한 데이터들
아니면 소스코드 데이터 할 수도 있고
우리 집에 있는 PDF 파일
네가 열어서 해봐
뭐 그런 PDF 파일일 수도 있고
그래서 유저 데이터는 좀 명확한데
KB Cache 풀은 조금
약간 낯설 수도 있을 것 같아서
그냥 간단히만 설명을 드리면
KB Cache 풀은 뭐냐면
결국에 이제
추론할 때 필요하거든요
KB Cache 풀이
그럼 추론할 때 왜
랜드가 필요하냐 라고 물어보신다면
모르시면 그냥
아 모르는 소리 하나보다
라고 생각하시면 돼요
인공지능이 추론을 할 때
프리필과 디코드로 나눠지는데
답변을 하기 위한
거의 모든 단어의 맥락 정보를 모아놓은 게
KB Cache거든요
그게 이제
컨텍스트가 거기에 들어간다
라고 보셔도 되는데
인공지능이 답변을 하기 위해서
나의 머릿속을 정리해야 되는데
그 머릿속을 정리하기 위한
데이터 용량이
메모리로 부족한 겁니다
그래서 메모리로 부족하다 보니까
그나마 메모리보다는 좀 느리지만
그 다음으로 빠른 놈을
메모리처럼 써야겠다
라고 생각하면서 쓰는 게
이제 랜드인 거예요
사실 이게 뭐 옛날에도
가상 메모리 이런 기법으로도 쓰여서
옛날에 컴퓨터들은
이제 메모리가 부족하면
하드디스크를 메모리처럼 쓰곤 했었죠
그러면서 여러 가지 문제들을 해결했었는데
뭐 그런 거랑 비슷한 개념이에요
어쨌든 간에 그냥 뭐 쉽게 말하면
메모리가 부족하니까
랜드도 와서 메모리처럼 행동한다
이렇게 생각을 하시면 됩니다
본질은 이거예요
인공지능이 더 많은 일을 하기 위해서는
더 많은 데이터가 필요하고
데이터가 필요해지는
그런 어떤 변곡점적인 순간이
지난 한 6개월 사이 아니었겠습니까
그러면서 메모리 회사들도
주가가 많이 오르는 거고
메모리를 보조해서
보조해 줄 수 있는
메모리가 다 저장하기엔 너무 비싸니까
메모리 대신 저장해 주고
또 속도가 메모리보다는 아니지만
그래도 빠른 랜드 같은 업계도
워낙 업황이 좋은 거죠
뭐 이게 언제 끝날지
뭐 이런 건 모르겠지만
이 레오폴드라는 분은
긍정적으로 보시는 거 같습니다
이 24살에
만 24살에 레오폴드라는 분은
적어도 이번 분기에 한해서는
샌디스크에 대해서
매우 좋게 보는 거 같다라는 생각을 하면서
물론 또 다음 분기 되면
뭐 루멘텀처럼
한 분기만에 바로
올릴 수도 있을 것 같기는 한데
이런 AI 천재들은
이런 주식들을 담고 있다
이런 오픈 AI 전 연구원의
포트폴리오를 참고하면서
여러분만의 AI 포트폴리오를
만들어 나가시면 좋을 것 같고요
저는 13F를 좀 더 읽어 보면서
흥미로운 게 있거나
아니면 또 그 외에
딥한 기업 분석들을
앞으로 좀 더 할 생각이니까
구독과 좋아요
알림 설정 부탁드리겠습니다